what is autism what do we know about
autism
human beings exist on a spectrum of uh
how social we can be
and this is pretty interesting actually
scientifically but also
very important clinically
there are hypersocial states where
people are
almost too social there are chromosomal
deletion states where people have
instant affinity and bonding and and
rich deep uh seeming connections with
people very verbal
on the other end
people
with autism spectrum disorder are
not
able to
keep up with social interactions and
it's it's a spectrum some have
mild to moderate difficulties they
may have inability to understand what
the next thing to do in a social
situation is but may have perfectly good
language abilities
and as you progress further along the
spectrum that gets more and more severe
so they
can't make eye contact because it's too
overwhelming to think about what has to
be done next if a person looks in a
particular way yeah
and then as you go farther then
language
and social communication themselves
break down so there's no reciprocity
there's no shared enjoyment
and that this gets very hard then as you
get to this far end of the spectrum
where there's
really an absence of social cognition at
all uh and and social bonding
so why why does this exist what is it uh
it's very genetic as i mentioned it's
it's one of the you know top three or
four most biological in the sense of
most genetically determined of the
psychiatric illnesses it does have these
interesting positive correlations slight
positive correlations with intelligence
and education
and
the reason for that is kind of
interesting to think about
is there something good about it just
like
or
at least with at least part of the
spectrum is there something good about
it just as we were talking about for
depression
as you could say for mania as you could
say for schizophrenia
and
here it's kind of interesting to think
about the
the underlying science of what it means
to be good at a social interaction the
someone who's very good at a social
interaction is incredibly good at
dealing with unpredictable
information
is able to handle this torrent of
information coming through
rapidly changing
uh
model of the other person and of the
interaction and their model of you
your model of them
with each word that changes with each
new bit of information that comes in
through the conversation each bit of
body language all this is rapidly
changing and some people
are
able to keep up with that fire hose
information perfectly well
but that's a special brain state to be
in that's working with
unpredictability that's
know uh
the only way that can be done is most
likely by constantly
running models of what the other person
might be about to say
so you can't stop and think oh what did
that word mean what did that
shift in eye contact mean you know what
do they mean together there has to be
some advance work going on where you're
predicting what's going on if you're to
keep up with a rich and fast social
interaction
now
on the flip side
there are
brain states that maybe don't have to
work so fast that are extremely
important still dealing with something
that's not moving
or that's predictable still complex
like
uh you know mathematical proof or very
complex arrangement of geometrical
shapes a large number of individual
non-moving things
there's a
possibly a way of being that's
particularly good at dealing with these
static unmoving or predictable
situations
and less so with these rapidly changing
social situations
and so the way i conceptualize autism
is these are people who whose brains are
not so good with the high bit rate
unpredictable information but maybe
quite good at giving enough time
given
the
grace to work with
the system
to look at it from different angles
uh to take different perspectives with a
confidence that it's not changing
in between perspectives
uh that's a brain state that's valuable
it's something that has probably
has contributed to a lot of the success
of the human family being able to design
something be able to consider
the
the
all the different contributions to a
static predictable uh
system
so autism in a sense is a
is a spectrum that has
identifiable characteristics about the
way people deal with dynamic information
often expressed itself as like social
that's right dynamic information but you
critically your use of the word often
there is really i think smart because
it's not just social interaction that is
a challenge in autism and so many people
conceptualize it purely as a social
dysfunction uh
disorder
but
it's really any unpredictable
information that's a problem that's a
challenge for for people on the spectrum
they react very
negatively to unexpected sounds even if
not social sounds unexpected lights
unexpected touches
and so it's really unpredictable
information that is uh in my view the
core problem with with the processing
and autism not just social social just
shows up because it's so unpredictable
yeah that's so interesting i mean um
i tried to not to think about that stuff
um
i'm afraid of thinking disor about
disorders and things like that because
just like i don't like sort of economics
or game theory
uh i won't be careful with it because
it uh whenever you have a category or a
model it's too easy to just
uh for every i mean it's the ocd thing i
like models too much i like categories
too much the moment you acknowledged
yourself well i have an eating disorder
for example or something like that as
opposed to just being a well i'll just
i'll just leave it at that for my own
critical understanding of myself uh
let's just say i don't know how to
moderate eating fruit people make fun of
me they think all fruit just fruit is
healthy
i know
[Laughter]
i don't well i don't know how to
moderate anything but even even fruit uh
this apples and cherries is a nightmare
anyway
that's just like hydras things say very
interesting um
but uh
but there's characteristics and and i
it's
it's interesting to think about like for
example i have trouble making eye
contact
but i actually as you said it now
it's not that i'm shy
at all in that sense
it's literally i'm getting way too much
information it's distracting me like i
need to just close my eyes so i can
like all the things that people seem to
be able to do in parallel it's just
you just ask me a question
for me to think about the answer to that
question i can't have all this cool rich
visual information coming my way that's
literally because i often close my eyes
to think it's not because i'm afraid of
something whatever it's just like too
much information happening here yeah
well that's a beautiful description it's
amazing that that is how you experience
the the eye contact
aspect
i think that's
i mean you've articulated what uh
you know
captures it for for so many people which
is that it's overwhelming there's just
just too much information just coming in
through the eyes
and
to keep up with it to know
you're going to be expected to keep up
with it first of all so there's that
that aspect you know you learned
socially that there's going to be an
expectation if you're making eye contact
people are going to think you're keeping
up with it and
you don't want to because you want to
focus on other things and make progress
in other
you know dimensions
yeah and so that then there's a strong
desire to look away or to close the eyes
because
it's it's it's overwhelming it's a
distraction and it's going to cause
errors of understanding and of course
our eyes that's part the way we use our
eyes as part of the human communications
you have to kind of be aware of that
of that um
that element of it so yeah i mean but
it's fascinating you should be aware of
your own self and those those little
characteristics
whether it's uh
whether it's classified on some aspect
of the uh autism spectrum or just in
general whether it's eating
whether it's depression
whether it's um even like schizophrenia
that would i hope we get a chance to
talk to a a little bit yeah but those
things are all made up of different
charac
symptoms and characteristics
and
use use them as a superpower i i suppose
this is the best we can hope for in mild
cases
i guess i do think both brain states
can't coexist at the same time the way
of dealing with something unpredictable
and dealing with something predictable
there those are different ways of being
here's a huge opportunity for
very creative
model building in theoretical
neuroscience
and linking that to these data streams
we're getting across the brain
that we talked about earlier these
immense data sets of activity across the
brain
here's where i think there could be a
real convergence of theoreticians and
experimentalists to say okay
given what we know about wiring of the
brain
here is what
the brain state is likely to be that
deals well with unpredictable
information and here's the brain state
that deals with predictable information
here's why they're incompatible at least
at the same time here's why you've got
to be able to detect
which state you should be in here's how
you could switch between them
here's the kind of cells that you would
predict almost like predicting the higgs
boson here's the kind of
circuitry that i would predict should
govern the switching
or
might make one
state too sticky too hard to get out of
right yeah that is a huge opportunity
for an interaction from the theoretical
and experimental side together
make one state too sticky
the
sort of uh measure the stickiness of the
stay and how to lessen the stickiness
that's right get some oil in the machine
yes yeah what would predict the kind of
oil that would work well
uh what in your practice is um
treatment or advice
for the people on the autism spectrum
so right now there's no real medical
treatment there are behavioral
treatments
that are most effective early in life
they make sure people don't fall too far
behind
if you're not interacting socially you
create this
you know vicious cycle where you fall
farther and farther behind because
you're not interacting and these these
therapies which are applied early in
life
therapists work with the kids
train them to deal with these things
that otherwise would be aversive to them
teach them how to predict things and
interact and that
has a big effect but it's behavioral
therapy there's no medicine that works
there are ways of reducing individual
symptoms though that sometimes come
along with autism and those do respond
to medications so you can you know one
thing very often my patients with autism
are very anxious
because
they live in a world that they have a
really hard time predicting what's going
to happen and so they find
and some of these are high functioning
you know silicon valley types who you
know they may make you know great
livings but they're very unhappy because
they're on the spectrum
they
don't
understand how social interactions
really work they're very
uh anxiety provoking because they don't
know what to say they don't have any
clue how anybody else knows what to say
they're constantly worried they're going
to say something that's completely
inappropriate and so they're very
anxious and i can i can treat their
anxiety it doesn't touch the autism per
se but i can help them with their
anxiety
what i just talked about eye contact
i
am richly even with eyes closed and all
those kinds of things i'm richly
experiencing the world and it's not like
you're afraid of the world or you're not
able i don't know what to do no i know
everything in fact i know way too much
there's so many cool options like at any
one moment
there's all the stuff happening and it's
all beautiful and at any one moment you
can do anything you want you can take
off your clothes you can punch that guy
over there you can uh
run away you can go in for a hug you can
say something profound and deep or you
can say something generic or you could
use so many things you can say
and then and then it'll go it'll unravel
in all these kinds of ways and this
moment could be completely life-changing
or it can be
mundane and meaningless and all of those
options are before you at any one moment
and so that's amazing
it's amazing and overwhelming if you
allow yourself to think about it yes
which uh
whatever exactly like unfortunately with
chess you have a few
set options two dimensionals these
dimensions constraints
there's unlimited possibilities and
unlimited beautiful things happening all
around you so i don't think there's a
kind of sense that somehow you're
limited
in your
in in the places
of uh
in the way you can see the world and how
you can interact with that world i am
overwhelmed by
the lack of limit
that all of us should be have you looked
around you can do whatever the hell you
want nobody will remember you anyway mo
all of us will be dead one day you could
do anything
you can uh
i don't know you can get naked and run
around the city as long as you're not
hurting anybody and it doesn't matter
so it's austin anyway
exactly seems like
uh a to-do item for anybody living in
austin for sure yeah
but you know the
the spectrum is an interesting concept
because
that is you know when i say when i refer
to the spectrum
uh i'm actually referring to it's a
precise clinical term but you're right
it's been co-opted more broadly and it
is widely used and it can be
an unfair categorization of someone
who's
socially and occupationally very healthy
and that
is critical
because we we don't define a disorder
unless there's social or occupational
dysfunction it doesn't matter what the
symptoms are i've had
patients who are pleasantly
hallucinating so frankly psychotic but
doesn't affect their lives so i don't
give that person
as diagnosis because there's not social
or occupational dysfunction
same with
any anything on this
you know any of the diverse symptoms of
autism spectrum disorder
if someone has them but they're
successful socially and occupationally
we don't say that there's a disorder
but then you're right the concept of the
spectrum does become a useful uh you
know pigeonholing
device which is maybe not not the best
thing
yeah and eye contact is an interesting
one
it's an interesting one i'm torn on it
i'm torn about the usefulness of eye
contact because people kind of make fun
of it but
uh let me just say one thing about eye
contact and about life in general it's
okay to be weird
but like some people when you have your
eyes closed and there's that weird what
is happening to this creature like you
see a weird creature on the side of the
road it's interesting
yeah and you wanna i mean the the weird
stuff i'm gonna go back to robin
williams with the that's the good stuff
right he has that whole speech about him
and his wife
and what he loves all the little
peculiarities all the weird stuff and
that like um
let those flourish yes
like celebrate those in yourself and not
in some kind of woke way but in some
like very human way this is what makes
us this is the weirdness yeah
i i'm 100 on board with that i
and i don't think
you know
people who are
happy and who have
people in their lives
who are happy with them these are
i think let let the weirdness flourish
let the let the
all the different ways members of the
human family can be different let's see
them all that's one of our
that's one of the joys of being alive is
seeing all the ways we can be human
and i think about it all the time
why
do we have all these ways of being human
uh
and
even within one individual you go
through phases of life where you express
different
sides of your way of being which is also
a pretty fun opportunity right you can
go through
phases where you're in one mode and
phases in another mode
and let that you know just
let that let that flourish too let the
ways that you can be you uh vary as well
i think that's important for people to
explore and i should
like because if you can address the uh
the
uh the internet but i i would like to
sort of ask the internet
to celebrate
the uh
the the weirdness of people like that's
uh it's the robin williams uh
people call these imperfections but
they're not that's the good stuff for
any one individual person
find the weird stuff and celebrate it
as opposed to
what the internet often does which is
find the weird stuff
and criticize it
because when you criticize the weird
stuff you're creating conformity which
is another human thing
but that that conformity creates a a
boring
world you want the weird
you want the crazy that's what fun is
made of that that that's the uh the
foundation of humor and
the all the ways in which we deal with
the with the with the suffering in the
world with the injustices in the world
is
like this like
huge variety of weird okay
yeah i don't know
and that's what at the depth of
psychiatry is like you wanna
uh acknowledge the weird celebrate the
weird like step around it to find
the particular aspects of weird that are
debilitating like you said they're
somehow negatively affecting your
ability to function in the world as
opposed to trying to
shut it all down that's right
you